sera mena será el rey si el próximo jefe
de interpol el candidato de mira tia
está acusado de actos de tortura en
junio de este año el centro del golfo
por los derechos humanos denunció a
ahmed naser ante los tribunales
franceses por torturas contra el
activista ahmed mansur encarcelado desde
hace cuatro años dos ciudadanos
británicos también afirman haber sido
maltratados por al rai si en emiratos
denunciaron al general ante la justicia
del reino unido por detención arbitraria
y torturas
su abogado argumenta que el alto
funcionario emiratí es responsable de
los abusos
hoy nos preguntamos cómo es posible que
alguien como el general al rais y
responsable e inspector general de
prisiones de los guardias y los
interrogatorios como alguien como él
puede convertirse en jefe de la interpol
una organización que tal y como
establecen sus estatutos tiene como
objetivo investigar los crímenes de la
interpol constituye una inmensa base de
datos una mina de información para los
194 países miembros que emiten las
llamadas alertas rojas utilizadas para
localizar y retener personas requeridas
por la justicia internacionalmente voces
críticas temen que los regímenes
autoritarios abusen de la base de datos
aunque los propios países pueden limitar
el acceso a sus archivos el secretario
general también debe evitar un mal uso
de las informaciones de la organización
si resulta elegido ahmed naser al dry
site podría ser reemplazado en su cargo
actual de delegado de asia en el comité
ejecutivo de interpol por el candidato
de china el expolicía houbens en lo cual
preocupa a distintas ong que temen que
su llegada permita a beijing endurecer
la represión contra la disidencia